great uh
so like jp said i'm trevor linda
i work at the new york times
doing mainly javascript i think like
most of us here well you mentioned the
server side but maybe it's javascript
um
and i work on the mobile team i worked
on the mobile site and we're on a new
app now
um so a little bit about this talk did
that animate by the way yes didn't do it
on my screen okay
it's important
um
so a little bit about this talk it was
actually really hard to
figure out what it was going to do i did
the description but to actually figure
out what i was going to talk about was
pretty difficult because some libraries
are do a lot of things like angular has
tons of stuff ember has tons of stuff
and fit that on the slides was
not easy
so i didn't do that
but there are some pieces from
some libraries which you'll hear about
in a moment
that you'll find in here
the important part about this was that i
actually learned some new things
just by creating a talk about it
and you can do the same thing
but in the intent to learn how to use
the library better
and you can figure out maybe some
performance things that are under the
hood from it
an extent or how to make your own
library
so what i'm actually going to be talking
about is
or what i'm going to be doing through
this talk is making a library of myself
and implementing some of these practices
from there and while those don't always
make sense for this use case uh it's
there for the sake of the talk
um
so there's going to be a lot of code and
i'm going to step through it and if
there's something you understand um
it's mostly plain javascript if you
don't you don't understand something
just let me know and i'll it's probably
quick to explain
um so
again it was difficult to decide what
libraries to choose from
i just went with jquery common one and
not to mention the description
backbone underscore
because they're smaller and easy to pick
out from
there's a snippet from angular
and should json mocha and if you're
unfamiliar with any of those i'll go
over them again
um
so
this is my base
library here it's just a
uh collection
um and it's an array like object that
we're going to use
and i say it's really like
because it has things that you can do
that are like an array but it's not an
array
so let's get into this
um first we're going for jquery i'm sure
we all know what that is dominic dom
manipulation library and has some other
tools built into it that don't really
make sense but they did at the time when
they were implemented
my library doesn't do anything with the
dom though
it could actually
but there's not any dom usage here
um so i don't know if jake was the first
one to use no conflict
but it
was really important for usage when
people were putting in different
versions of jquery into their websites
because they were blasting away old
versions of jquery and that was a really
big problem because it would break code
on deprecated methods
etc so
it's a pretty simple idea we make a
reference to
the old library that was set on the
window object at this point
and from there we can call a no conflict
method on a local variable and that way
it gets reset back to where it was
we don't have to worry about blowing it
away so if we log these two
methods we'll get an object and a string
because i had set it to foo
but we can kind of get away with this by
using a common js style
modules anyway
sorry
next is length this is uh if you
actually look at the jquery source
you'll see a length property
and it's just defaulted to zero
and by using array methods
with context on this we can actually
just let the array increment the size of
our collection as it goes
so if you're unfamiliar with the call
syntax or apply syntax let me know and
i'll go over really quickly because i
use it a lot
since we're dealing with a collection
which usually
means there's a lot of parameters going
through
so simply
do a radar prototype that pushed a call
with the context of our collection and
we use push just as we normally would
since we're using call here
and we can verify that the length is in
fact two
um this is a big one in jquery you
realize you can pass a string of html to
it you can actually pass a regular dom
element
you pass a function for dom ready
a lot of things um it's kind of squished
to fit in here
but
for this case i'm allowing
the collection to accept any number of
arguments
whether it's an array it's array-like
in this case we're assuming there's a
two-array method
for that
so if we look at the use cases down
below
pass in the array with one two three
or comma separated
and lastly we have an object just with a
two array that returns an array
obviously we could probably pass a
collection directly into this and
automatically put that inside this
collection as well
so and we can even expand on this to
accept any number of arguments we want
uh the logics has to be there
oh
yes at this point would you ever
consider also
uh checking if you are a collection type
and recalling yourself with new
uh that was a i remember about four or
five years ago that was a big
oh how to save people from cool from the
new we don't call you i'm particularly
not a fan of that i think if you're
going to use use new you should
be responsible yes this is the option
yes
there is hinting in this uh if you look
at the source
um
cool so let's move past jquery
and we'll move into backbone so a little
bit of background here for people who
didn't
don't know about it but mostly it's
about some pretty unique uh well not
unique all of them
uh functions that are inside of it
so we're going to ignore
some of the stuff that is
built
for like building mvc
mostly but you could use this for part
of your collection part
so inside backbone if you've never used
it before collections get a ton of
methods off of underscores collections
collection methods but they make it
easier by instead of having to call your
collection directly on an underscore
method by automatically putting the
method into it or calling it with
context of that
of the class you're in so uh this is uh
ecmascript55
um
method on object for get on property
names which is the only way to actually
get
methods off arrays
but we don't care about all the methods
we don't want to blast away length we
don't care about constructor or the two
strings
so simply we're going to iterate over
the functions
are the function names uh skip them over
there inside our array
and then add a new function which simply
calls our array function
with the context of our class so that
way it will act like uh as we saw before
with length will get updated
in this case it's always going to return
a new array but we could obviously
modify this to make it return a
collection as well
we can validate this by
making use of this inside of our
constructor and do push on there instead
of using the array prototype directly
so we can check the length on the
constructor time and then we call on
shift to put a value at the beginning of
our collection
you can trust me that does in fact do
that
um on and trigger
which are what we kind of hit on before
are events that are built into it
um we can actually
see what happens when any of our events
are occurring so the basics are we're
going to do on the collection when push
occurs
some function is going to be called that
we provide
and when we call push with our
parameters it's going to call that
function
this is not possible without
object.observe some sort of data binding
unless you did a set timeout
but this is obviously much cleaner than
set timeout which would be a pain to
manage
this is the only way you can get
you will know when the
properties are changing at all and so
here's implementation of on
first of all we need to a way to store
the methods or the the function event
name sorry
um so
we'll just make sure one exists or not
if it doesn't we'll set it as an empty
hash our object
and then we'll actually create an array
that will store each of these events
that we're going to push onto it
and then we're going to add the list
this is how we're going to add the
listeners
next we have trigger this is how we
actually fire set events
we're going to make sure that these
events exist first otherwise there's no
point in doing the rest of the function
if you're unfamiliar with
slice it's just a reference to array
prototype slice which will convert an
array like object such as arguments into
a regular array
but by providing the value 1 we're going
to shift off the
the name because we don't care about
that we're actually calling the event
so we'll use that name
to actually retrieve the events that are
set for or that inside the events
we're going to iterate over them and
call all the events that are bound on to
that
um so let's see it's in our let's see it
in the api so this is the same function
we saw before of creating all the
push on shift etc array prototype
methods
and all we have to do is say
this.trigger
with the function name and the return
value that was back from that is how i
implemented it
one line just to get that information
uh
to json or 2json however you want to say
it
is actually an interesting
implementation as part of the spec of
json
and
basically what it does it allows you to
return
what you would want jason stringify to
actually output
so without that
if you look near the end of the comment
which says without method
if we didn't have that two json
function on our prototype it would
actually output
zero
spot has one and one has spot
has two and two and three etc
but with two json we can actually give
an array representation which is what we
really want to see
like my understanding is that you'd want
to return
something that looks like json but
why well it is it is going to be json
but because i have my own object defined
here
and i'm making it act like an array it's
actually just storing
the 0th index and whatnot in
an associative manner so as you notice
they're actually strings like zero
string
but when
we use it on array prototype it's
actually going to hit each of those
through indexes
but if you run json stringify it's going
to run it naturally normally
and therefore it's just going to output
all those and we'll actually get any
other properties around there too like
length and we don't care about those
so we want to iterate over it as if it
was an array and so that way it's only
going to do the indexes
and it'll return the values only so
it'll look like an array and when jason
stringify gets that array it's going to
stringify that array instead
this is pretty handy since your server
wants to see that not
the object style
um so i only picked one from underscore
uh though i do suggest to look at
underscored pretty deeply
um it's highly functional
and it's a
really good learning experience from
there but
um one bit i really enjoyed about this
so this is basically reimplementation of
zip
which allows you to take multiple arrays
and put the same indexes inside of a new
array for each index that they are set
in
so the cool part is is using
map and other methods together so
uh the second line lengths and uh the
third line length
is where the interesting part is um
we
take our objects in this case we're
going to pass it an arbitrary number of
collections
we're going to map back to that a new
array of lengths so it could be 2 3 4
are going to be an array
then we're going to go to apply math.max
on this with each of these lengths so we
can get the maximum length so when we
actually need to zip these together
we can already have a pre-pre-allocated
array to fit this in here so we don't
get any resizing performance issues
now here's one i actually could pick out
from angular
that is the rest of the example well the
how is that i'm confused by the
um
so you're counting on
in the for loop you're counting on i
being in the function scope
is that second to last it's the last map
that i'm confused by
oh sorry i wasn't
trying to talk too much about that but i
can go into it
um so
the last map is the is the zipping part
yeah
this is a synchronous process the map is
the map function's right above it
so it's going to go over each index
of each of the um
okay you see
so it's going to go over each index of
each of those arrays
and return the value so
it'll hit zero spot in each of those
arrays that's where the map occurs
and that's going to return a new array
and put that in the zero spot of our new
array that has been pre-allocated
sorry i can go over that again
the cool part is
the idea is to you you want to use like
map and other things in tandem uh just
for single values purposes
so
here's one pretty cool thing in angular
that i found out there's a lot of cool
things but not many of them fit into
this slide or are easily
transferable into another library
but i didn't know i didn't know this at
all
there's actually
a huge performance hit when you use
apply
on your on uh functions
so
this js jsperf which you can go to
afterwards
um
shows that
when you use up to
10 arguments
instead of using apply on each of those
it actually has
almost 10 million um
operations per second
as opposed to six million operations per
second so it's
a huge difference especially if you have
a large data set and say you want to
create a new collection for each of
these like 10 10 million spots so
there's 10 arguments per collection and
there's 10 million of those so this is a
huge performance win
because it's going to take a long time
to initialize all of that
and since tons of people are going to be
using this api we definitely want to be
performant
so this is basically an action
we're going to use our performance apply
instead
which is going to take the arguments as
it did before
uh it's going to be on the push method
and it's going to be called with this
um so to look back at that
we can see that args is the first
argument to go into this
the function that we want to call on and
the context of what it's going to be
now there might need to be another
version of this if you just wanted to
call without context but for the sake of
this api it's built that way
um so mocha is a testing framework for
javascript
server-side client-side whichever if you
haven't heard of it you should
definitely use it
uh it's fantastic
um
and i just learned this a couple days
ago as well jason stringify actually
takes more than one argument
you can pass it a
a replacer function which is the second
argument and then there's a third
argument that allows you to actually add
spaces and format it
so
wrapper or representation
is something from python where you can
easily just pass out um
show values that are inside your object
or whatever what have you
so in this case
um i had to overwrite to json so
it doesn't use that stringified version
and the replacer is kind of like an
iterator where it gets a key and a value
and you can check the value inside of
that and return it
and that will be inside the json that
you actually want to see
so
excuse me
um the reason there's that weird bit
self equals val
is because the very first iteration the
value is the same as the object
and you have to return that otherwise
it's going to return
undefined and the void zero is just an
alias for undefined as well
but it's it's safe because it can't be
overwritten
and after the iteration is over we're
going to delete the instance to json
which will set to json to work back to
normal
that was really like the only cool thing
in mocha everything else was really
testing specific
to stay inside testing
we have should js which is an assertion
library
it uses ecmascript 5 descriptors getters
and setters if you haven't used those
before this is a fantastic library
because that's all it uses
and even puts it on object.prototype
which
people might scream at you about
so first we'll do
get
it kind of looks funny in comparison to
how you've probably regularly been
writing your javascript
so ignore the params it's just the
syntax that follows
but those don't actually take anything
so these are accessible via
collection.size
so why would you want to do this
in the case of the size it's just an
alias
and this dot length could not be bound
to
as a property as it would just be a
reference because it's a primitive
so this way size will always reference
what this.length actually is
and maybe we want a faster way to get
the jason stringified version without
having to call jason.stringify every
time
so instead we can just have
collection.json and that will return
stringified version
uh and the my favorite parts are defined
property
which that text looks kind of funny um
we're going to look at this familiar
function again now or it should be
familiar anyway
instead of setting it directly on the
prototype
using equals function
we're actually going to set it with
value
as you can see inside the defined
property line
and the value is just the same thing as
you would said if it was equal
and then we do the exact same thing
we're doing before and there's other
parameters such as enumerability and if
that's a new
if that's omitted
it's automatically set to false and then
when we do for loops or four of loops
it will actually be ignored so that's
how that's exactly how
get on property names works too
those properties are ignored because
javascript regularly sets them like that
as well
and there's also
writable so now these functions are
protected they cannot be overwritten by
someone else who's doing something
irresponsible
and there's also configurable which
means they can't be deleted
and by default those are all false so
this
all the
all the methods on the prototype are
officially safe
so we can actually look at the whole
source here
um this is the url uh just slash landa
learning from libraries i could have
made that shorter
but we can actually see that inside i've
got my apply function as i mentioned
before
we have
our collection working as it did before
and we have all of our stuff on our
prototype
there's anything that anyone wants to go
over again i'm happy to look at it
and here we actually have defined
properties more
uh thought out so we can go see the
other uh actions there
so we have our value initially set to
zero as we saw but it was before it was
just set directly on the prototype so
this is using defined property
so we can actually say that it's
writable and it is in fact enumerable
and the rest are just some helpers and
what we discussed
but inside here again we can say let's
use define property to make sure things
are not overrideable
and we want the events object to be
definitely be safe
don't think there's anything too extra
special in here without if you just need
to look over it
and uh
that's it questions